[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقه جديده من
حلقات اخبار دوله الاحتلال واخبار حرب غزه
وصديقنا الدكتور احمد فؤاد انور مساء
الخير معال الدكتور اهلا سيد بيه صديقي
الغالي الله يخليك ويحفظك ايه اهم يعني ما
شغل الاعلام اسرائيلي في الايام القليله
الماضيه منذ ان التقيت انا الاسبوع الماضي
هل مسار العمليات العسكريه ام المبادرات
المختلفه لانهاء الحرب يعني مسارات الحرب
طبعا في ثمن فادح بيتم دفعه
في قطاع في الوسط والشمال والجنوب بشكل
غير مسبوق لذلك بيصفوا الامر بانه كارثه
الخسائر الكبيره التي تحدث من خلال ضربات
المقاومه وعلى شكل الموازي في
الصفقات التي يتم الحديث عنها من خلال
وارثو ان في مفاوضات بيجر رئيس المساد في
وارسو برعايه مصر والولايات المتحده طبعا
وقطر والصياغه العامه الملامح العامه
تتحدث عن ثلاث دفعات كانه احياء ل 30
نوفمبر الذي توقفت فيه دفعات التبادل
الاسرى والمحتجزين بين الجانبين فالحديث
ان المرحله الاولى من ا ثلاث دفعات ثلاث
مراحل لانهاء
الحرب المرحله الاولى باختصار هما 90 يوم
بنتكلم عن المرحله الاولى باختصار مدنيين
يتم اطلاق سراحهم من غزه اسرائيليين طبعا
مقابل مئات من
المعتقلين وايقاف الاستطلاع الاسرائيلي
الطائره الزنانه والخروج من المدن القوه
الاسرائيل تخرج من المدن المدن مخيمات
بتحصر من بره لا نبتعد للحدود المرحله
الثانيه
هما المجندات والجثث الافراج حماس عن
المجندات السيدات والجثث اللي ههم الاسر
اللي قتلوا في مقابل ان اسرائيل قتلوا يوم
سبعه وقتلوا في اثناء محاوله اسرائيل
تحريره اه و اطلاق صراح عدد كبير من عدد
اضافي من من السجناء الفلسطينيين وتقليل
القوات من الاماكن السكنيه برض ثاني المهم
ان المرحله الثالثه هي الاصعب اللي هي
الخاص
بالعسكريين ان تطلق المقاومه كل بقى كل
العسكريين مقابل بقى انهاء الحرب احنا
بنتكلم على المبادره الرئيسيه اللي شاغله
الراي العام الاسرائيلي الان هو فكره
المبادره المصريه القطريه اللي اللي بترع
الولايات المتحده وال يتفاوض عليها رئيس
الموساد في 90 د يوم دول يبقوا 60 ولا ايه
مفض وان هي من ثلاث مراحل خلاصتها كده
يتبادلوا الاسرى و في
مقابل وتنسحب اسرائيل من غزه يعني ينهوا
الحرب ونتنياهو زعم للاسر اسر العائلات
بان يا جماعه حماس لم تطرح شيئا انا اللي
طرحت بس مش هقول تفاصيل اه ده صحيح فنتكلم
90 يوم 60 يوم المقابل هو لم يفصح عن
التفاصيل لكن يعني رشح من الاعلام ان
المراحل ثلاثه وخلال 90 يوم او 60 يوم
عظيم جدا دي هي المبادره الرئيسيه وطبعا
كان في مبادره سعوديه المبادره السعوديه
بتقول بتربط بقى التطبيع مقابل حل شامل
مقابل دوله فلسطينيه هي برض هي مع اسرائيل
اه بالضبط هو يعني بيسموه ايه المبادره
العربيه على مراحل على دفعات مبادره
العربيه 2002 يعني اه اللي رفضتها اسرائيل
تنفذها على مراحل انت اديتي حاجه للامارات
اديني انا حاجه مقابل حاجه شخصيه اوكي
للامن القوم السعودي لكن ايضا حاجه كبيره
للجانب الفلسطيني طبعا اذكركم الدكتور
احمد بيشير الى انه كانت الامارات طلبت في
مقابل التطبيع معها اللي هي عدم ضم الضفه
الغربيه بالضبط الغاء الضمه ده كان وعد
انتخابي من نتنياهو وتراجع عنه وطلبت حاجه
ل نفسها ان صفقه اسلحه متطوره طبعا
بالنسبه للسعوديه احنا اتكلمنا على القصه
دي كتير ولكن هي قالت انا عندي تكلمنا
عنها في حلقات اخرى هضع لكم روابطها لكن
خلاصتها دلوقتي ان السعوديه قيل يعني
تسربت السعوديه لا يتحدثون ولكن الامريكان
والاسرائيليين بيقولوا السعوديين مستعدين
للتطبيع مره اخرى مع اسرائيل في مقابل كل
الشروط السابقه اللي هي الشروط الخاصه بيه
هي بقى مع الامريكان انه معاهده دفاع امني
واسلحه متطوره وبرنامج نووي ودوله
فلسطينيه يبداوا التفاوض عليها بالاضافه
طبعا ان هي سوف تساهم في اعمار غزه الفكره
بقى ان انهاء الحرب لازم له ضمانات ان
الولايات المتحده تطلع تقول بقى احنا مع
حل الدولتين انجلترا تقول مع حل الدولتين
نتان ياياه نفسه يقول ان ما فيش مانع
واللي لفت نظري انه انا ما قراته يعني انه
اسرائيل بدات تطرح فكره كانت طرحت قبل كده
لا اعلم من اي من الوسطاء احنا بنتكلم على
وسطاء متعددين لكن لكن بشكل اساسي مصر
وقطر هو فكره ان هي عادت تطلب انه انا
ممكن استجيب لوقف الحرب بس تخرج زعامات
المقاومه الى الخارج انها بدات تطرحها في
المفاوضات الكلام ده دقيق اه لا دقيق هو
الفكره ان بتحاول شق صفق المقاومه تقول ان
التيار اللي في قطر القيادات اللي في
الخارج مكتب السياسي موافق اه هو الفكره
مش مش حماس الخارج وحماس الداخل الفكره
انت هتديني ايه انا شخصيا ولا هتدي للقضيه
الفلسطينيه حاجه اذا كانت ملموسه والراي
العام يقدرها خطوه كبيره للامام اعتقد
اللي يضحي بحياته ويموت ممكن قوي يخرج
يطلع المنفى منفا ط بمناسبه ديني ايه هل
المفاوضات دي اكيد بتتكلم اكيد هدف
المفاوضات بالنسبه لحماس ان انا اديكم كل
الاسر اللي عندي في مقابل ان تق في الحرب
واخد السجناء الفلسطينيين وضمانات بعدم
مواصله اسرائيل الهجوم على القطاع وعلى
المقاومه بعد ان تسترد اسرها مين اللي
هيضمن مين اللي هيقدم الضمانات دي اولا ان
قدره حماس على الرادع لسه دي مهمه وامريكا
يعني طبعا هتبقى ضامن اساسي ومصر ده يعني
جزء اساسي ومن بيجعل من الصبه و مكان ان
المفاوضات بتبقى معقده ليه وبتاخد توقيتات
دي كلها يعني ده دي نقطه مهمه وخاصه
النقطه الاولانيه ان هي فكره انه قدره
المقاومه على الرد بالبط وبتي اسرائيل
هتتمنى انها تخرج ما ترجعش تاني يعني لان
اه النهارده احنا بنسجل النهارده يوم
الثلاث اللي هو 23 ا 23 يناير اليوم ال
109 في الحرب النهارده كان الاعلى خساير
اظن منذ بدء الحرب في الجانب الاسرائيلي
مظبوط اه بيوصفوا الموضوع ده بانه كارثه
اه وطبعا كارثه يعني مرتبط بالاحداث
الضخمه النازيه فوصفوه بانه كارثه ومتحدث
العسكري قطع العاده بتاعته ان هو بيتكلم
بالليل وفي معاد محدد ومش كل يوم خلاص فج
بدري الساعه 7:00 صباحا اعلن ان هو هيلقي
بيان استثنائي وطلع قال 21 الاول قاله 10
ق يعني نحكي القصه مش كل الناس عارفينها
ايه القصه ا القصه ان في قوات اسرائيليه
في وسط قطاع غزه في احد المخيمات قريبه من
الجدار الفصل بين 48 واراضي غزه حوالي 600
متر في بيتين متلاصقين ا من بيوت
الفلسطينيين ا مكون من طابقين القوات دخلت
الاسرائيليه جيش الاحتلال عشان يجعل ده
مقر ليه مؤقت ف
وكانوا بيحاولوا يزرعوا الغام ت نسفوا بها
متفجرات ينسف بها بيوت ثانيه لان هو قريب
من اراضي الثم الاسرائيليين اللي بيحاولوا
يزرعوا الغام في المنطقه اه اه فال
المقاومه اختارت اللحظه دي ولغايه دلوقتي
التحقيقات بتقول مش عارفين هو طلع منين
المقاوم ده في مقاوم طلع غالبا من نفق حسب
الجانب الاسرائيلي وضرب الدبابه اللي
بتحرس الجنود اللي جوه وفي نفس الوقت حد
زميل ليه ضرب المبنى نفسه فالمبنى جواه
متفجرات فبقت الخسائر فادحه واصابات وطول
يعني الواقعه بدات يوم امبارح الساعه 4
العصر اه لم الجثث دي استمر لغايه الفجر
اه يبقى هم مش كانوا بيزرعوا بقى الغام
كانوا بيجهزوا الالغام اللي زرعوها يعني
او المتفجرات جز اتحط قدام المنطقه وفي
جوزء اتحط جوه المباني علشان يفجروا مباني
قريبه ف كان نوع من ممتلئ بالمواد
الانفجاريه بالضبط بالضبط دي دي عمليه
لازم نعرف تفاصيلها في اول ما تظهر اي
تفاصيل لانه واضح ان هم بقى كانوا مراقبين
راصد منهم ما هو كل ما القوات الاسرائيليه
تقعد قوه القطاع بيبان الروتين بتاعها انا
ببدا اتحرك من هنا لهنا ازاي ببات فين ما
انا مش هبات في الخيام انا بقتح البيت من
الباب فانا ممكن كمقاوم الغمه ولا بيحموه
من زاويه ثانيه من حاقط معين في كل مره
فابتدا انا اعمل حسابي ان انا الغم او
استعد بالار بي جي الار بي جي والتي بي جي
وال الياسين ابتدوا في نوفمبر اللي فات
يتم استخدامهم بكثافه وده وزنه 4 كيلو
يعني يسهل ثبات الرامي
واستهداف المضارعات الاسرائيليه وده راس
مزدوج ويمكن ب اقتحام المباني فده من ضمن
الاسلحه برض اللي عامله خلل لجيش الاحتلال
وبتسبب في خصيات
كبيره طيب ده عن
تطورات الحرب حتى الان وعن اخر المبادرات
اللي طرحت يعني هل ا انا شايف بعتت لي انت
عناوين كثيره قوي بتتعلق بمصر هذا الاسبوع
اي يعني ضباط سابقين مسؤولين سابقين رجال
دين بيتكلموا عن مصر بشكل سلبي ممكن ناخد
بسرعه كده اهم ما كتب عن مصر من ناحيه
وبعدين نفهمه في اطاره العام يعني هو طبعا
في حخام مسؤول عن صفد دي من المدن الاربعه
المقدسه في بالنسبه لليهود في اسرائيل لها
مكانه دينيه لها مكانه زي العتبات كده
الدينيه فهو قال ايه هو حخام رئيسي
للمدينه دي وعضو الحاخام
الرئيسيه اسمه شموئيل الياهو شموئيل
الياهو دوت مطلوب العداله هارب من العداله
بمعنى ان المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه سنه
20 قالت ده راجل عنصري وتصريحاته ايه
تصريحاته هو مش ضد مصر ولا ضد الفلسطينيين
ولا العرب هو ضد الاغيار يعني ير
اليهود وده ما شاء الله ابنه هو وزير
التراث اللي قال نلقي قنبله دوريه اه ده
ده اه اه اه فدي دي الخلفيه فهو بيتكلم ان
بيقول من ضمن الفتاوى يعني ان الترانسفير
والترحيل ده بالنسبه له العادي انما بيقول
ما تاجرو للاغ ياار ش ما تبيعوش
للاغ اراضي او اغيار يعني لو راجل امريكي
اللي هو بيدفع من ضرابه عشان وبع حملت
الطائرات يقول لا ده مش تبعان اه اه فانا
عايز الراي العام يبقى فاهم ان العقليه دي
صعبه جدا ان هو مش ضد فصيل مثلا حماس
هيخلص منهم ده وور بعد كده على المسيحيين
بالذات لهم عداء شرس مع بيحمل لهم عداء
كبير طبعا طبعا اه ف هو قال يا
جماعه احنا لازم ننتبه ان مصر تتنامى
قواتها العسكريه هو فرعون مش كان عنده
عربات وكان مختال بيها وحاول ان يبدن او
يقضي علينا او يطردنا عربات عسكريه عربات
عسكريه وانتصرنا ربنا كان معانا وفي 67
كان في جيش قوي لمصر وطيران ودبابات وربنا
كان معانا فاحنا المره دي برض جيش مصر قوي
بس ربنا معانا ف بيفكرني بشمون بريز شيمون
بريز في استطلاعات الراي
النهائيه ليله الانتخابات شيمون بريز رئيس
وزراء السابق رئيس دوله اسرائيل السابق ا
قبل اي انتخابات سنه كام يعني سنه ا يعني
انا افتكر الحك بالضبط 96 96 اه كان قصاده
نتنياهو وقال ا يوجد رب ربنا كبير انا فزت
وبعد كده طلعت النتائج
النهائيه ربنا ما ن سروش على
نتنيا فايه فانت يا سيدي شموئيل الياهو
هوكى اخواتك اكى اخواتك ربنا كبير وفي مصر
في اضعف حالاتها في الاستنزاف في ايلات في
راس العش وما كنتوش بتطلعوا بالليل في
سينا طول السنوات دي خوفه من الصعقه
المصريه يعني خدنا خط برليف
بالكامل يعني في اضعف حالاتنا ربنا ما ن
انا بس اللي مندهش لله يعني يعني انه في
هذا
الوضع يعني فكره استدعاء او الحديث عن
مواجهه مع مصر يعني بتالي مش يعني مش
متدينين كده المتدين يقول اصل مصر عايزه
تضعف ن اه هي عايزه تضعفها من ايام طب ما
ده صحيح ما ده يعني طفنا مين ده احنا
عندنا يهود مصريين انا بعيد عليهم في عيد
ميلادهم في الاحزان بواسيه ليه لان هو رفض
الخي احنا بتتكلمش على اليهود احنا بنتكلم
على اسرائيل ما هو ما هو مش بيقول ان من
ايام فرعون هو فرعون كان ما ا صحيح صحيح
بيخلط الديانه بالقوميه صحيح فهو اولا
لازم نرد عليه ولازم نكشف خلفيته الحاجه
الثانيه ان ده خط يعني وجدنا ان مقدم سابق
في المخابرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه ايضا
تحدث بقى ان مصر بتجهز في سينا تحت الارض
ا عتاد وبتجهز مقرات وان في قوه وان مصر
هي الخطر على بتجهز يعني بتستعد عسكريا
لمواجهه عسكريه ايو اه هو بيقول كده
بالضبط اه وان عندنا وان وان مصر من سنه
56 وهي عايزه تضعفها بيقول ان مصر اللي
اسست فتح حركه فتح وانها يعني بتبقى سعيده
لما تكون المقاومه عماله تنهج فينا كده
لان مش عايزين كمان يبقى في نفسه اقتصاديه
وان في
يعني جار بهذا الامكانيات يعني لازم يكون
في فبالتالي لما حماس تبقى قويه والمقاومه
قويه ده لمصلحه مصر ف بيقول ده الخطر
القادم مصر نفسها بتجهيزاتها دي ودي برض
نغمه شغاله طوال الوقت انتم بتجيبوا
الاسلحه دي انتم عندكم
الحدود تجيبوا الاسلحه المقاومه منين يعني
لا العكس مصر بتشتري اسلحه ليه اه اه اه
ده احنا في سلام و كده ويعني طبعا الحدود
كلها مولعه دلوقتي حوالين انما هم من زمان
كانوا بيرددوا الحكايه دي بتشتروا اسلحه
ليه مش انتوا هتضربوا ب مين مش مش هم بس
والله انا فاكر ان عدد من المسؤولين
الامريكان كانوا دايما يطرحوا القصه دي من
وقت لاخر واذكر منهم ديفيد شينكر اللي كان
مساعد وزير الخارجيه وكنت اعرفه الفتره
يعني لما كان هو بيشتغل في مركز بحثي انا
ناسي اسمه دلوقتي يمكن معهد واشنطن للشرق
ام وفوجئت ان هو كتب مقال بيقول يعني مصر
بتعمل ايه بكل السلاح ده المفروض ان هي
بتستهدف عدوها الاساسي هو الارهابيين اللي
موجودين في سينا فليه الاسلحه الهجوميه
وكانها بتستعد لهجوم على دوله طبعا
يعني امر غريب جدا انت في سؤال انا ماحدش
بيسال لو هو مصر يعني واكيد نس الكلام
هيبقى على الاردن وغيرها يعني اذا كان مصر
من الغريب ان هي تشتري سلاحا لانه لا يوجد
عدو يجب ان تستعد له ليه اسرائيل عندها كل
هذه
الاسلحه صحيح يعني ما دام الاردن لا يجب
ان تستعد وما فيش عدو ليها ومصر ما فيش
عدو ليه هي بتستعد لمين هي بتستعد لمين
بالاسلحه دي صحيح صحيح هل حزب الله وحماس
يقتدي سلاحا نوويا واسلحه عابره للقارات
يعني هم ما بيسالو السؤال ده لا لا هم
شارين 100 طياره جديده دلوقتي الدفعه جايه
كده عاجله غير الجسر الجوي اللي بدا من
يوم 7 اكتوبر اه طيب هذا عن مصر في القضيه
الاكثر سخونه الان وغريبه ان هي تكون يعني
الاكثر سخونه وهي فكره اعاده طرح حل
الدولتين الاعلام الاسرائيلي والساحه
الاسرائيليه بقت ذاخر بالحديث عن حل
الدولتين ممكن ام غير ممكن طلعنا كده على
ما يجري يعني بدات الحرب والحديث عن تغيير
الشرق الاوسط نتنياهو ووعود كبيره وندمر
حماس هو دلوقتي بيقول انا حماس ما قدمت
ليش عرض انا قد مع عرض بالنسبه للمح بقى
يتفاوض مع الحماس الجزء الثاني ان بقى
الحديث يومي عن دوله فلسطينيه بدل ما كنا
هنخلص من ال 1% المتبقيه من ارض فلسطين
التاريخيه اللي هي غزه حوالي 1%
ا فده تحول لحديث بسبب المقاومه وصمودها
وبسبب الزخم الدولي وعدم تصديق الروايا
الاسرائيليه فبقينا نقول ان بايدن بيتكلم
عن الدوله الفلسطينيه
وطبيعتها بقينا نتكلم عن انجلترا بتقول
انها مصدومه من مواقف نتنياهو بازاء
الدوله الفلسطينيه فهو نتنياهو كان قال
انا طول ما انا موجود في السلطه يعني لن
تقوم دوله فلسطينيه هو في بعدين البعد
الاول ان ما فيش دوله فلسطينيه هتقوم في
شهرين ثلاثه هو فاض له شهرين ثلاثه فماش
الحال الحاجه الثانيه ان هو نفعي ان هو
بيقول حاجه وعكسها ان هو من
2009 كان في بار ايلان جامعه بار ايلان دي
جامعه دينيه في اسرائيل
وقال حل الدولتين وانا ما عنديش مشكله
ابدا مع دوله فلسطينيه منزوعه السلاح
بجوار دوله دوله اسرائيل وقال كده في
الامم المتحده 2011 اكتر من مناسبه وكان ب
ايامها يعني اوباما بيضغط وبيحب يسمع
الكلام ده فكان بيسمعوا الكلام ده
فبالتالي في الليكود قالوا له احنا الحزب
بتاعنا البرنامج السياسي بتاعنا ما فيهوش
دوله فلسطينيه انت ازاي تخش قال لهم لا
انا قلت اقل من دوله انا هديهم انتوا بس
افهموا انا عايز اوصل لفين انا هبتدي
اتراجع بقى وهو الفكره كان في تسلل كده
يعني الصهيونيه دخلت ازاي لارض فلسطين
ابتدت تتسلل كده عايزين بيت قومي في بس
عايزين يعني حط على العمله بس حرفين الف
ويا بالعبر ايه الالف ويه فلسطين خلاص
مكتوبه بالانجليزي ومكتوبه بالعربي
وبالاختصار ده هو طلع ايه ارض اسرائيل
فانت مش واخد بالك ان الحرفين دول تمهيد
لان هو عمال يتوسع عمال يسيطر فهو دلوقتي
ده معلش ققول الحكايه الالف واليه دي تاني
اه العمله المعدنيه الف اللي هي ايه يعني
اختصار ارس اسرائيل اسرائيل بتتحول ليه في
العبري احنا بنحول الف فهو ارس اسرائيل
الالف الحرف الاول واليا بقت مكتوبه على
العمله المعدنيه اول اشاره اول توا اللي
كان بتداول في بدايه القرن العش يعني
الانتداب هو اللي حطه الداب حطه على
العمله المعدنيه فده كان تسلل احنا بنقول
ايه ما نديهم بيت قومي يعني ايه بيت قومي
نديهم موطئ كان نتنياهو عامل كتاب اسمه
مكان تحت الشمس دونا بس مكان تحت الشمس
دلوقتي مش طايق 1% من فلسطين تبقى مع
الفلسطينيين عمال يخترع هو دلوقتي انا
شايف ان في مؤشر للتراجع لدرجه ان في اوبن
هايمر اللي هو اليساري الاسرائيلي اللي
اشرنا ليه اكثر من مره بيقول يا جماعه
احنا مش بنتكلم على دوله فلسطينيه احنا
بنتكلم هل دوله اسرائيل هتكمل بعد كده ولا
لا الطريقه اللي انتم ماشيين بيه دي تدمر
الصهيونيه بيكلم مين كلم الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اه لما قال لو سرنا على هذا
المنوال من سياسات نتنياهو مش بقى مش
هيكون في دوله فلس فلسطين مش هيكون في
دوله اسرائليه ما فيش دوله اسرائليه وفيش
صونيه فكان في بنج فير دخل في الخناقات دي
قهم يا جماعه على فكره المشكله الاساسيه
مش دوله فلسطينيه المشكله الاساسيه في ان
احنا قلنا خطوط حمراء تحولت للون البمبي
قلنا الخطوط الحمراء اللي تحولت لب قلنا
مادخلش وكود دخل وجود قلنا مش هندي فلوس
للسلطه الفلسطينيه دخلت فلوس السلطه
الفلسطينيه فاحنا ما عندناش رضع ما عندناش
القوه اللي تخلينا نتمسك بال الهدف من الح
او الخطوط العامه
للكابينه الحق بمناسبه حكايه انه اسرائيل
بتتسل يعني او الصهيونيه انا فاكر تعبير
لحيم وايزمان لما كان لسه بيدش او بيعمل
لوبينج
ل وعد بلفر فكان ليه عباره مشهوره بيقول
احنا سوف ندخل فلسطين كما يدخل الجمل الى
الخيمه قالوا له يعني ايه الجمل والخيمه
قال ما هو الجمل ده جسمه ضخم عشان تدخله
للخيمه صعب بس اذا ادخلت راسه الى الخيمه
يبقى من المؤكد ان جسمه سوف يدخل صحيح
لاحقا يعني تلقائي يعني خلاصه اللي انت
بتقوله لنا انه انا عايزين نوصل بس تتعلم
من عدوك ان العمل تراكمي اه ابدا خطوه ثم
طالبك ادخل راس الجمل اه دوله منزوعه
السلاح يا سيدي خد دوله ورينا بس مين اللي
هيعرف ينزع السلاح يعني جيش الاحتلال دخل
ما عرفش فحنا بنتكلم على صيغه لبنان ان في
دوله وان في جيش لبناني
وجنبيه مقاومه بقى ايه اه انت بتقول رايك
ان ممكن الفلسطينيين يقبلوا بدوله منزوعه
السلاح ثم بعد كده ي نبقى نشوف ه ننزعها
ازاي مين اللي هيجي ينزع السلاح ده اولا
ثانيا ممكن الامور تتغير يعني على الارض
يقولوا لا ناخد خطوه كمان نديهم مثلا
مضرعات طب بستقبل بقى التعليقات الليسو
فتاتيك مؤيده ورافضه في في طبعا في دي
رايك طبعا
انا ماليش دعوه بالقصه ديت يعني لا لا هو
سيناريو يعني اصل انت تاخد زي قلنا قبل
كده على العصفور في اليد خير من ع الشجره
وبعد كده احنا فين احنا دلوقتي ما فيش حكم
ذاتي اصلا اه عسكري الاحتلال يوقف الوزير
الفلسطيني وممكن يموته اه لا انا فاهم
طبعا وجهه نظرك وجهه نظر برجماتيه عمليه
بس تظل وجهه نظرك علشان اي تعليقات تي ما
تيجي هنا
بس تخصك يعني
طيب انا يعني في حاجه بس احنا بشتم في
جمال الاحوال يعني لو قلت العكس هتشتم بر
لا ممكن ما تقولش حاجه خالص ما حدش يشتمك
مع المقاومه بتشتم ضد المقاومه بتشتم في
حاجات كده لازم تتقال عشان ما تشتمش عشتم
الجانب الاخر يعني لا موضوع اللي بيتشتم
مع المقاومه دي قصه
يعني بس الوقت هياخد كل الوقت يعني انا
شايف ان في تيار يمكن ده من انجازات
اسرائيل ومن انجازات الراغبين في التطبيع
فعلا نجحوا في شيطنه الفلسطينيين بحيث ان
انت محتاج تبذل جهد عشان تقول الناس دول
من حقهم يقاوموا ولكن دي قصه بقى هو مثالي
تفريغ شحنه الضمير يا جماعه انا مش بتدخل
في المتده ولا اتعاطف ولا ل ده لان
الفلسطينيين باعوا قدهم لان الفلسطينيين
مقاومه حساباتها غلط اه حكايه حسبتها غلط
ما هو اكشات كده موجوده فخش ينام وضميرهم
مغح في في سؤال يعني دلوقتي انا وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي انا ماعرفش طبعا يعني
خلفيته ولا مدى ثقافته ولا كذا ولكن انا
عارف هو مستفز يعني زي تصريحات اسرائيليه
انا حقيقه عاوز افهمها يعني مش عاوز اسخر
منها الاتحاد الاوروبي ووزير الخارجيه
معاه بيدوروا على بيبحثوا حل الدولتين
الكلام ده اول امس احنا بنسجل الحلقه انا
قلت يعني النهارده 23 يناير ايه اللي يعني
ايه اللي بيدور في في ذهن وزير الخارجيه
خليه يقول بدل ما نناقش حل الدولتين ملائم
دلوقتي مش ملا دلوقتي يقول لهم افضل حل ان
انتم تبنوا جزيره في البحر المتوسط
وتنقلوا اليها الفلسطينيين يعني هو بيفكر
ازاي هو طبعا دي يستفزهم يعني ولا بيضيع
وقتهم اه في جزء منها ان هو انتم عايزين
تساعدوا خلاص يلا نملي جزيره يعني انتم
عندكم طاقه زياده عندكم فلوس زياده عايزين
تساعدوا الفلسطينيين دول نساعد بالجزيره
هو الفكره دي اطرحه سنه 18 وقالوا ان
الساحل قدام قطاع غزه يعني 2018 اه 2018
طرحت الفكره دي ان المياه ضحله امام غزه
فبس هوله ممكن
نعمل جزر هو الفكره ان عايز يفتت
الفلسطينيين وعايز يلهي الاتحاد الاوروبي
بمعنى ان انتم مش فلسطينيين لا ده انت
دروز وفلسطيني الداخل وفلسطيني القطاع
وفلسطيني الضفه وفلسطيني مقدسيين فما
تتفتت الكتله انما في جه في الناحيه
الثانيه عايز برض يلهي الاتحاد الاوروبي
انما هو بشكل عام يعني لا يجيد الانجليزيه
سبق ليه ان هو اتكب مخالفات قانونيه
لان هو استلم في يناير كوزير الخارجيه
بالتناوب وفق الاتفاق الائتلافي انما هو
يعني مش واجهه مشرفه في جمال ح يعني ما
بيقش اللغه الانجليزيه معناه ان كلامه كان
اكثر رشاده باللغه العبريه بس اللغه
الانجليزيه شج وزير خارجيه صعبه هو انا
بعرفش انجليزي صعبه كلم مع الناس ازاي انا
بس وجه اندهاشي انه ان تصريحه ده امتداد
لتصريحات ممثله الممثله ديت انه انا اجي
ادمر غزه بس اقول لك انه الاتحاد الاوروبي
ودول الخليج يجي عمروها
مثلا يعني انه لما اجي اعمل حتى بدون
تدمير هنعمل بناء دوله بس يجي اللي يتكلف
الفاتوره الخليجيين والاوروبيين ودول اخرى
طب انت ما بتشارك باي حاجه انت ده بيزم ان
هو تنازل كمان وقبل ان انت تيجي تدفعلي
وتعمللي اللي انا كسرته يعني طيب احنا
عندنا في حاجه اثيرت في الاسبوع اللي فات
وهو
ملف لعيبي كره القدم الاسرائيليين واضح
انه حضيه ببعض الاهتمام ايه القصه هو طبعا
الناس فجئ بان في لاعب اسرائيلي في الدوري
التركي احرز هدف فعمل الضماده الطبيه اه
عمل الضماده الطبيه قدام الكاميرا واحتفل
او ناصر المحتجزين والاص الضماده دي رمز
الايه الضماده طبيه عاديه بس هو كاتب
عليها 100 اللي هو 100 يوم ا 7 10 ونص قلب
مكسور اللي هو الاشاره كده بايده عملها ف
تعاطفا مع الاسرائيليين يعني النادي نشر
الصوره عادي ماخدش باله التركي لقى ان
التعليقات كلها ايه ده اللي جاي يعمل
دعايا للصهاينه عندنا وناصر الاباده اللي
بتحصل ومتجاهل فابتدع يشيلوا الصوره ابتدى
يبقى في وزير العدل يتحرك محاكمه تحقيقات
لمده 10 ساعات
وابعاد الفكره بس ان هي سياسه بينج بونج
معكوسه كان حضرتك فاكر الصين والولايات
المتحده والتقارب عبر مباريات البينج بونج
ده بقى العكس ان العلاقات بعد ما اتحسنت
بالرياضه بتسوق بالرياضه لان اللي مرر لل
الكوره في نفس الفريق هو لاعب اسرائيلي فر
تركي اه لاعب اسرائيلي يعني في اكتر من
لاعب في اكتر من لاعب منهم لاعب خط وسط
عامل زي راموس كده مؤذي
بيكسر في النادي اسمه شهير شهير دوت
النادي المفضل اللي اردوغان كان بيدعمه من
ايام كان عمده اسطنبول وفاز بالدوري لكنه
خسر الج ما ماهير بتاعه الانديه الاساسيه
الكبيره اللي كان بتفوز بقى يفوز على
حسابهم فده مؤشر ان هو عمل ايه بقى الاخ
ده عمل على انستجرام بعد ما زميله اطرد
والدنيا هاجت برض بوست مستفز على انستغرام
ان انا متعاطف وازاي متعاطف مع بلده
اسرائيل بلده اسرائيل ومع فالمهم ان هو
اتاخد برض تحقيقات
واجلاء طرد من تركيا بس طبعا ده هياثر
يعني ممكن تلاقي في الامارات لاعب
اسرائيلي هيبقى برض وضعه حساس بعد ما كنا
نقول ايه مافيش رياضه في السياسه والعكس
من ايام اوكرانيا وروسيا اتضح ان فييه اه
طبعا طبعا اذكر حضراتكم انه بامرين يعني
المثال اللي اشار اليه الدكتور احمد هو ما
يعرف بسياسه او دبلوماسيه البينج بونج او
تنس الطاوله اللي كان نكسن استغلها ان في
فريق امريكي هيزور الصين في سنه 74 على ما
اذكر و كان في وقت ما فيش اعتراف
بالولايات المتحده بالصين كانت بتعترف
بيوان باعتبارها هي الممثل الرئيسي لكل
الصينيين نيكسون استغل هذه المباراه و
لتذويب الجليد بين بين الامريكا والصين
وبالتالي ظر بعد كده الصين فاطلقت على ديت
دبلوماسيه البينج بونج ويبدو ان هو اصلا
جهزوا هذه المباراه وشجعوه علشان تبقى
غطاء ومناسبه الامم الافريقيه كان انا
اتفرجت على المباراه اللي اصيب فيها صلاح
المباراه الثانيه منتخب مصر بالتعليق
العبري عشان اشوف هم فما هاجمو صلاح مثلا
ولا هجم مصر كان اثنين معلقين مع بعض
بيعلقوا على المباراه الاصابه وتقعد
اسبوعين ولا لا وطلع بدري فممكن يخف بدري
ما فيش الترصد لصلاح لان هو طبعا ليه تار
بايت معاهم هم بيقولوا ان صلاح في الماتش
في اسرائيل كان بيلعب في سويسرا فكان جه
جانب المباراه بتاعه الذهاب فراح ربط
الحذاء وما صافح اللاعبين تعمد ده ففي
المره اللي بعدها المباراه القادمه واحرز
هدف وطلعهم المهم ان في المباراه الثانيه
خلاص اللعبه دي اتكشفت مش كل مره هيجيب
الجزم فبيعمل بوكسات اه ان هو بيصف قبضه
اليد اه اه فهم يعني بيترصوا لصلاح بس في
اليوم ده بتاع التعليق كان من فلسطين ال
48 هو
المعلق وحافظ اللعيبه وده كان في الزمالك
وراح الاهلي وهكذا فده برض اللي هو
الرياضه وتاثيرها على الراي العام وعلى
السياسه بس انت تقديرك انه حرب غزه يكون
تاثيرها سلبي على الدول اللي استقبلت
لاعبين اسرائيليين زي تركيا زي الامارات
زي دول تانيه زي مين مثلا في دول اسلاميه
تانيه بس مش حاضر في ذهني انما هو كرافع
لاسرائيل
تعويم اسرائيل الترويج ليها ان احنا يا
جماعه عادي وماتشات وده رياض وكان اكثر
دول استقبلت لاعبين وفقا لمعلوماتك اللي
هي تركيا تركيا طيب تمام هل عندنا مع احنا
كان عندنا واقعه ان في مساعد مدرب هنا في
مصر مساعد مدرب الكاميرا جابت وشم على
وبرتغالي جابوا الوشم شبه العبري الدنيا
قامت طبعا ولا ليه علاقه باسرائيل ولا راح
اسرائيل هو الحقيقه انه
مصر مصر
كحكومة اعتقد دي الحقيقه يعني انه على
مستوى الحكومات في علاقات يعني منذ مبادره
السلات في اواخر السبعينات لكن التطبيع
بمعنى التطبيع الدافئ انه ا لا مش موجود
لاا ما فيش فرقه موسيقيه تيجي جامعات
نقابات اكثر من كده وهو ليس سرا حتى
الصحفيين انا لو انا كصحفي مصري اذا فكرت
ان انا اغطي حدث في النقا مثلا في اسرائيل
اول حاجه النقابه هتوقف ني الامر الثاني
ان هلاقي مكالمات من
سه بيتصلوا اذا ما كانوش يعني عرفوا وان
رايح فين وهتلاقي العمليه صعبه يعني
فالكلام انه على مستوى الحكومات ماشي يعني
لكن على مستوى الشعب في حد قال لو رحت
وعملت عمليه فدائيه ورجعت
هقطعك حتى لو رحت حتى لو تعمل عمليه
فدائيه انا جزيل الشكر معالي الدكتور شكرا
يا سيد سعداء ربنا يخليك ويسعدك ونلتقي ان
شاء الله في حلقات اخرى باذن اللهن